à chaud il ya disons que j'ai a sorti
truc avec les talents et les lacs ont
dit combien en cuir en plus valeureux
des jeux pas encore mature mais
n'entendre aucun commentaire aucun
commentaire ça la limite de
l'humiliation et intense
[Rires]
ils n'ont pas perdu matin banny bien
décevant pour lui
[Musique]
moi je crache sur les mecs avec qui j'ai
fait ma carrière dans sa trace sur le
ring
j'avais toutefois pas d'après ces voies
rapides et voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non c'est pas ça mais c'est rigolo et
perd quasiment
[Musique]
le complexé après la la il irait aux
montres ton coeur et nous fera un bon
jour
[Musique]
tu penses que l'avenir à quelles
conditions
il faut d'abord parce que j'ai l'air en
bandoulière
[Musique]
tu veux pas savoir gérer
ils sont où ces enfants là bas ils sont
encore là bas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cependant
[Musique]